so it took you about eight or nine years
to work your way up from second
assistant director
to being a director on nurse jackie is
that right
yeah i mean it took i would say that
i would say in general it took eight or
nine years to go from
a second assist director to a first
assistant director
to the director on nurse jackie
okay so there were kind of three steps
to it okay yeah i mean
yeah their second sister then first
assistant director which you know gets
you a lot closer to
the producers the show runners the you
know the other directors who go off to
do other things you know
um as a second assistant director you're
usually stuck doing a lot of the
planning
and a lot of the kind of paperwork and
you know all the everyday kind of rests
on your shoulders
and any little failure falls on it as
well
so it's one of those thankless jobs that
you do to get
you know to the next level be it a
producer or a
first assistant director and
i i was a second assistant director for
one year on nurse jackie
uh and then i first assistant directed
that show for four years
uh season three season four
for four years or maybe it was three
years and then on the fourth year i
asked for an episode
so i said you know on my on that path
i said you know i really wanted to be a
director i've always wanted to be a
director
and you know i have to start doing
something
i shot a short and i did a you know
i shot and produced a short for like
three thousand dollars and we did a
small
festival circuit and i showed the you
know the producers of that show
hey look at this this is something i did
i would like to direct one day
here we go and then think oh this is
great look how great this is and then i
let another year go by and then i made a
spec pilot um and
we you know show i showed that to
to the showrunner of uh nurse jackie and
they were like this is great and i said
at that point is where i kind of had to
like put the
not the gauntlet down but just go look
i've been here for a long time
and i would really love to direct an
episode
uh and you know if i can't
i don't know if i should be here because
you know i you know if i'm not going to
move up then what am i doing
um you know i hope nobody kills me when
i sit
for saying that nurse jackie but
but you know that sometimes you have to
do that you have to kind of say
hey um i really want a shot
and you know i know i'm a valuable tool
for you
in this one capacity but just give me a
shot to just do one more it's just one
episode
so i got that one episode i um
it was the second episode of the sixth
season
and you know i had such a great time
it was a big episode uh
they had such a good time they really
liked it edie falco really liked
me i mean i had known her you know for
quite some time at that at that point
um but it was a fun it was like really
fun and it was you know they liked it
and you know everybody went away
like great great episode good job and i
went right back to assistant directing
the
you know the fourth episode i was the
assistant director
and then just you know by chance
halfway through the season the producer
came up to me and they said
uh do you want to do another episode
and i said absolutely and they go there
there's a director who wants to get out
of their contract they're supposed to do
episode 11.
um we think you know
she's asking she's you know she's under
contract to do it but she's asking if we
can cover her and get her out
and would you like to do it i was of
course so i did that episode
um it was the you know the second to
last episode of the season
and it went great uh it was another
great episode it was a beautifully
written episode by
liz flay hive who's now the you know
show runner and creator of
glow um and
the next you know the next i you know
eventually had to go get it
you know i went to the producers i go
now what do i do i was like i want to do
more of this
now how do i how do i do more like oh
you have to go you have to go to la
and you have to meet like showtime and
you have to meet the lionsgate people
and you probably have to get an agent
and i go okay i'll i'll do that so i go
out and i
you know i meet showtime and i meet
lionsgate and
um i get an agent
and i come back and i go back to a.d and
other tv shows at the time and uh
the producer calls me up and he said um
how many episodes do you think you can
do
and still be the ad in one year
and i said i think you're asking me the
wrong question
i go i know you'd like me as an ad
but if you like me as a director you'll
still get me as an ad
i will still whatever good i brought
i'll
as an ad in that capacity you know
thinking about the crew or thinking
about
you know i'll still i'll still make sure
that that happens
and they called my agent that i had just
gotten
and they said that they were they wanted
me to do six of 12 of the final season
including the uh season premiere so
i guess i did something right and um
you know that that last season was like
i like lived in a dream for like
you know the whole season i was i was
constantly prepping and shooting
episodes and editing and prepping and
shooting and editing and that's all i
did
for that last season and it was uh you
know it was the
the best time i've had on set
is that something that's always been in
your makeup to
be in one position but be preparing to
maybe move up you know because it could
be an easy thing to get stuck somewhere
sorry i was dead i mean it is very easy
to get stuck in one
spot and i would say i let myself get
stuck
as an assistant director for probably
too long
um mainly because you know i joined the
the director's guild you know the money
was good i had a young
family i was like this is great and
there wasn't enough
pushing me to like go and and
you know chase this um i did move up
fairly fairly quickly
through the dga or from in the assistant
director path
um and i've always told people and i
think
i'm pretty sure someone said this to me
you know i i
tell people from when they're pas that
you always have to
you always have to be ready to do you
know you always
want to be good enough to do the person
above you's job
and if you know i i say it when i when
i hire anybody it's like you know you
want to do it enough so that you
you know if you want my job i you know
not
not in a in a sneaky way but you know
you want to be hey i can help you do
that i can do this
you know like can i you know let me do
that for you
and you know i've had plenty of people
who've worked underneath me and
you know especially in the assistant
director kind of category i've had
plenty of assistant directors who
have gone from you know a a pa for me to
a second second for me to a second for
me to
now first on another show and and you
know and i always say that to them i'll
be like i'll let you do all the job
as well you know but that's like you
have to kind of
keep proving that you can do that job
you know you you
i you there's a little bit of you that
wants your job
that wants that job the whole time um
if that makes sense yeah it does and it
sounds like
from what i'm hearing that you made it
easy for them to see that you were ready
for the next step because you had this
short
and i think you said you did a spec so
it wasn't like you just went in there
and
pounded your fist and said you know
don't you see my worth
you also showed them with other things
it sounds like
yeah i mean you have to you know you
it's not just like throwing your weight
around
um uh you know
you have to do some of that as well um
but yeah i gave i had something to show
i had something to
to to put in front of something tangible
that they could be like
okay you know because it is a risky
it's a risk that everybody's taking
handing a director or anything you know
i mean we're
it is a business so when you're handed
an episode of something of a
kind of a major show i mean those those
can be between
four to 12 million dollar episodes i
mean you're handing somebody for the
first time
hey you're now in charge as much as you
think you're in charge
for the of this and you know and people
can
really you know you can screw that up
uh you know and
and that and that's just that's where
you know you separate yourself from the
business and you go
okay i need to prove the investment
if that makes sense i need to like i
need to give you something to take the
leap
you know that they can they can see like
okay i think you can do that
and and they i mean they even sent it to
show time they had to send it to
showtime to even get me approved you
know like look at this he did this on
his own
it looks fair it looks professional it's
you know
well done um
and you know and that was that process
you